identify all sets of parallel and
perpendicular lines in the image below
so let's start with the parallel lines
and just as a remember just as a
reminder two lines are parallel
if they're in the same plane and all of
these lines are clearly in the same
plane they're in the plane of the screen
you're viewing right now but there are
two lines that are in the same plane
that never intersect and one way to
verify because you can sometimes it
looks like two lines won't intersect but
you can't just always assume based on
how it looks you really have to have
some information given in the diagram or
the problem that tells you that they are
definitely parallel that they're
definitely never going to intersect and
one of those pieces of information which
they give right over here is that they
show that line st and line u v they both
intersect line CD at the exact same
angle at this angle right here and in
particular it's at a right angle and if
you have two lines that intersect a
third line at the same angle at the same
angle so these are actually called
corresponding angles and they're the
same if you have two of these
corresponding angles the same then these
two lines are parallel so line st is
parallel to line u v and we can write it
like this line st line st we put the
arrows on each end of that top bar to
say that this is a line not just a line
segment line st is parallel to line to
line u v and i think that's the only set
of parallel lines in this diagram yep
now let's think about well now let's
think about perpendicular lines
perpendicular lines are lines that
intersect our R it lines that intersect
at a 90 degree angle so for example line
st is perpendicular line CD so line st
is perpendicular to line CD and we know
that they intersect at a right angle or
a 90 degree angle because they gave us
this little box here which loading means
that the measure of this angle is 90
degrees by the exact same argument line
U V is perpendicular to CD so UV let me
make sure I specify these as lines line
UV is per
radicular to CD so I did you V St the
perpendicular CD and then after that the
only other information where they
definitely tell us that two lines are
intersecting at right angles our line a
B and WX so a B a B is definitely
perpendicular to W to W X line WX and I
think we are done and a one thing to
think about a B and C D those are
definitely not
well they don't even intersect in this
diagram so you can't make any comment
about perpendicular but they're
definitely not parallel you could even
imagine that they looks like they're
about to intersect and they give us no
information that they intersect the same
lines at the same angle so if somehow
they told us that this is a right angle
even though it doesn't look anything
like a right angle then we would have to
suspend our judgment based on how it
actually looks and say oh I guess maybe
those things are maybe those things are
perpendicular and then actually it
actually or maybe these two things are
parallel but they didn't tell us that
and that would actually be bizarre as it
looks so not parallel and actually you
would have then this would end up being
parallel to other things as well if that
was done but and it's good thing that
wasn't because it would look very
strange but get based on the information
they gave us these are the parallel and
the perpendicular lines